here's how to create a meeting
invitation in tungl me click schedule a
meeting and in step one we'll take care
of the
basics we add a subject
line set our meeting
duration and add an optional location
and
message in step two we invite
people you can start typing to search
your address
book or simply type in an address to add
them in step three we propose Times by
clicking and dragging in the
calendar the default is for tungle to
pick the final time once everyone has
submitted their choices if you prefer to
pick the final time simply check the box
here
here in the final step we can choose
whether we want tongle to send the email
invitation or if we want a private URL
that we can send out ourselves through
email over Skype via LinkedIn or any of
our social
networks